Let's discuss the security of HMAC.
First of all, the security of HMAC
depends on the cryptographic strength
of the underlying hash function.
That is, the underlying hash
function used in HMAC must satisfy
the basic properties of one wayness and
collision resistant.
Further, compared with
the cryptographic hash function,
it is much harder to launch
a successful collision attack on HMAC.
The main reason is that a secret
key is hashed together with
the message content.
As a result,
without knowing the secret key,
an attacker cannot
compute the correct HMAC.
For example, supposed the attacker is
able to obtain the HMAC of message M1,
and he wants to find another message
that have a collision with M1.
That is, a different message
M2 that's not the same as M1,
but had the same HMAC value as M1.
But without a secret key,
the attacker cannot compute
the correct HMAC value for M2.
That is, the attacker does
not even know whether M1 or
M2 will have collision in HMAC.
In summary,
because of the use of the secret key,
HMAC is much more secure than
a cryptography hash function.